only on cbs this morning oprah winfrey
is revealing her latest selection for
her book club
take a listen so one of the great joys
for me
is finding new authors and i am so
thrilled
to introduce you to a debut author
with his debut book the sweetness
of water by nathan
harris the sweetness of
water the sweetness of water takes place
in the days immediately after the
emancipation proclamation the novel
follows the story of two formerly
enslaved brothers and the white family
that hires them after the brothers
walk free from the plantation where
they've spent their entire lives it's a
fantastic book
and the author is a very interesting
fellow we sat down with him
as well as oprah as she announced her
pick and spoke
with both of them about that unique
moment
in our history and i'm very
happy to be joined now by oprah and
nathan harris and nathan
was here live watching you make that
announcement
and smiling to himself got to be a
surreal moment
one of the most surreal moments i've had
in my life
i would say yes a person who works in
imagination did you ever imagine a
moment like this one
no never in a million years
i remember when oprah made the call
my editors told me i had news and uh i
thought it was bad news
i actually got hives and i was going to
urgent care
so i was kind of panicking what's going
on and then i get the call from her
and there's no better uh cure for hives
than a call from oprah oprah
is fda approved to cure hives many other
things as well
yes yes i think dr fauci would support
that uh oprah
it's an unusual book because it's
historical fiction a lot of people don't
write that
also it's about the 60s and i'm not
talking about the 1960s which a lot of
people write about but the 1860s and not
the war period
but right after which nobody'd ever done
that i'd never seen anybody do that and
and as i was reading it to tony i was
like oh yes
of course what would those first few
days weeks
months years be like and then when i
found out that it was
a young 29 year old who wrote
this book i was like how did that wasn't
that my first thing to you wasn't that
my first thing to you
how did you do this yeah i how did you
do this
you guys i wish there was a good answer
for it i was just as curious as you were
i mean i feel like history class goes
from the civil war
to reconstruction i was thinking what
were those moments like you know and in
my mind
those two brothers are on the plantation
and it was almost like
the gate swings open yeah you can go you
can stay
you can do whatever you want and and the
two brothers go
we're walking out of here no no
no way we stand another minute i know
you brought that to life so
you know vividly that i wonder did you
study a lot of history
did you read a lot of books prior yeah
yeah there was um you know i i read a
number of
oral histories oral narratives taken
down from slaves talking about their
experience um
freed people and the second i started
greeting them i was almost like
i want to sort of not read more so i can
let my imagination take over
people walking away with their freedom
but with no resources no power
very little political agency i never
thought of that
that moment in our history and here it
is on the page so clear
were there parts of the book that you
read
thinking there's a line i can draw from
this moment here all the way to today
and things that are still with us
i think um one of the things that's so
relevant about the story
is that you can feel the essence of what
it means to have come
from there to here that's why i liked it
so much is because
you get to to literally look at how far
we have come
yeah what do you hope people take away
from it gosh i
as you were talking about i think the
past resonates um so much in this novel
and we're dealing with
today issues of race issues of class and
the scars of the past
and i guess i want this novel
and what this community faces to show
that
we can come together in a way there is
hope
and um there is a chance to be uplifted
but we have to have empathy for people
who don't look like us
people who you know again are from a
different class and we can do that
oprah do you see significance uh
symbolic or otherwise in the book coming
out so close to
juneteenth yeah because i look at it as
really kind of a juneteenth celebration
it's a perfect book
for reading at exactly this time
and a great book to take with you no
matter where you're going this summer i
couldn't agree more
may a million readers pick it up
and i think they might all right i think
they might and
come to oprah's bookclub.com to talk
about it
and then may a million conversations
follow jonathan i want to talk about it
this is the thing you're going to want
to talk about it
and the thing is i'm always reading when
the books aren't out so i don't have
anybody to talk to
so you're going to want to talk about it
come read with us and talk about it
all right oprah thank you very much
nathan congratulations thank you so much
thank you and congratulations
thank you guys so much
so i have read the book you guys can't
talk about it because you haven't yet uh
it is terrific it is a
towering towering achievement of
imagination uh and nathan is a heck of a
guy to route four he's only 29 years old
he wrote a lot of this book uh in his
mid-20s when he was working as a
delivery guy for postmates
and he's really made good on a parent's
dream here his father wanted to be a
novelist ended up being an english
teacher
uh so nathan is making good in a million
ways here yeah he sure is i just started
at 25 boy
now i feel inadequate i know not at all
you've achieved so much
what's so fascinating about this time in
history is after emancipation you had
all these black codes it's basically
controlled
black people and and you know it was de
facto slavery still
but then with the reconstruction act of
1867
black people served in congress they
were on state legislatures and
on in the south but of course that only
lasted a few years before
white supremacy you know took over and
reversed all that yeah you know andrew
johnson became president after lincoln's
assassination he had a very different
view of the union's role in the south
and we are still dealing with the
repercussions
this book will help you imagine what
that was like and also you'll be
entertained and like oprah said you're
going to want to talk about it
we'll talk about it the sweetness of
water is on sale now